hello everyone welcome back to the
channel for another sundance 2021
interview i'm very excited about this
one because i'm mighty obsessed with the
screen life format and i've got director
carrie williams here carrie
congratulations
the reason i didn't say the title of
your movie is because that's my first
question because i was saying it
differently before
and after watching your post screening q
a so
what is the title of your film romeo and
juliet
okay i do like asking in general
about coming up with a title for a film
because that's a very important part of
it so maybe what was the working title
and how did you decide to ultimately
uh structure it as our
you know hashtag j which we are out loud
saying romeo and juliet instead
right well it actually it came to me as
our
j when i came into the project they
already had that
uh but during the course of the you know
development of
it it was kind of like that doesn't
really work for
social media it's got to be hashtag rj
rhesuj is kind of like you know so
hey let's call it romeo and juliet but
just have that and i think it
kind of has like a little bit of an
iconic feel of just the r hashtag j it
speaks to
the style of the movie and what it's
what it is
uh but romeo and juliet most people will
immediately know what that is just
spotted your dog in the background and
i'm a big animal lover yeah
yeah i got two two little ones that run
around they like to come and make a
you know appearance whenever i'm doing
this you got the advanced warning my cat
deputy dewey is going to be in this
frame at some point
yeah when when exactly did you get
involved
in the development of the story because
i know there are two other people i
believe credited on the screenplay here
yeah yeah so i mean uh bazloves and
interface films approached me a couple
of years ago
after my short was at sundance my short
emergency
and they had they had a script um
for this story and they told me they
wanted to do a romeo juliet in screen
life format
and i was like okay interesting you know
i
i had no idea how to do a a screen live
film i'd never
i but i'd seen a screen light film uh
and i thought it worked you know it was
searching and it really uh
it really you know drew me in i thought
it was really great
so i thought to myself i'm like okay
this could be a great opportunity to
uh not only sort of push
you know my own you know filmmaking
boundaries
but also a great opportunity to put
people of color in like this
iconic story you know so i was like
yeah i think this would be a great movie
to make i think the world needs
something like this now
and we'll be doing something that really
gives romeo and juliet i think like
a reason for another form and another
like version of it
you know so i know timor was also
involved in this so was there any
opportunity to connect with some of the
other directors he'd made screen life
movies with to i don't know get some
pointers tips and tricks yeah yeah yeah
i mean you know timor is the og
like he he created this this format so
um
yeah i did uh speak to the director of
searching anish
and he gave me some you know some
pointers some some
good thoughts and uh i was really
thankful to him for that because i
i was like first of all how do you write
a script in this format
and how do you you know what are some of
the ways to shoot it
um editing process and he was really
gracious enough to give me some time to
talk to talk it through
you know i think that's really important
to you know be able to
communicate with other filmmakers about
some things you know just to get to
bounce feedback off you know
stuff like that thinking about anisha's
journey too it makes me want to ask you
this
having had the experience making a
screen life movie as your first feature
is there anything that you experience
working in that format that you think is
going to benefit you on your next films
whether or not
they're screen life movies oh hell yeah
absolutely i mean
first of all every time you do a project
you better learn something and take that
[ __ ] to the next thing i mean just
hands down no matter what it is uh also
it could be
something not to do again but you're
gonna learn something but
i think i think that for for me with
this project
it was um trusting my gut a lot
you know and trusting because you're
always it's all choices you know you're
always making choices all the time as a
director like
and you can second guess third guess but
trusting it and it reinforced
uh what i kind of knew before with like
in the edit
you can really reshape things
you know and rewrite the films we did a
lot of that in this project but
the great thing about screen life is
that it gives you so much more
flexibility
to rewrite the film in in the post side
of it so
um that was something i think i really
did because i was already outside of my
comfort zone
and i was like well let's go for it
let's go for it let's go you know and
that reinforcing trust in my gut was was
a good takeaway
do you think that you could have
directed this without having had editing
experience yourself
you know i yes i do because i had
an amazing editor and uh lam team win he
he uh we pre-visit the film completely
beforehand
and this guy was just like amazing with
like
his first of all his his storytelling
ability but also his just work ethic
um so i think so but it did help me
having my editor i think
having edit background for any filmmaker
is very key
just knowing what you need to get in
you know when you're shooting but one
thing about this is that you're not
doing
all the you know shot reverse shot and
getting all this coverage in screen life
you're doing
it's in the phase and is this so it's
like that part of it
the okay do we need this shot for the
edit as much
goes away a lot in in screen life so
yeah i think so
most people who are watching this
interview they haven't seen your movie
yet so
what is maybe a light non-spoiler
example of something that you envisioned
one way
through the writing and production
process and completely became something
else in the edit
oh gosh
everything you know i mean honestly i
have to say that
making this film um
and when i say making it editing it
during a year of a pandemic
and during such a tumultuous year really
really informed what this ended up being
i think there was so much awful stuff
happening
um in the world and you can't
shut that out when you're making
something it gets into your bones and
there were some days i was like i have
to not
work today i have to just you know step
away but
anyway i think it i think it sort of
propelled me to
look for more love in the story to find
more more moments that will make
you feel good or make you care about our
main characters
so that influence um
you know was one thing and also just
adding more commentary about what you
know social commentary to the film
based on what's happening in the world
so i think everything
really got tweaked in a way and you
couldn't you couldn't see the script of
this
and then watch the movie and go oh those
are the same movies other than
oh the characters are the same but so
much
change yeah how does
shooting a movie screen lifestyle change
your approach to working on set as an
actor's director
i asked them a lot are you okay is that
good
you know like i really checked in a lot
like because
i think all of us were doing something
we hadn't done before right um you know
the actors were literally just right to
camera
you know doing their thing and not
having someone to play off of
in a scene and i think that's really
really important for
uh for an actor to have someone to play
off of
and not having that i wanted to make
sure they were cool
you know like how are you feeling about
that take was it you know do you feel
like you were connected was it good and
you know usually they they took to it
really quickly which was
amazing um you know kudos to them
that's just for fun because i might have
been a kid who
did something like this in high school
what would you
think if someone sought out your movie
rather than reading the text to get
through class i am
not telling anybody to go do that but
i might have been one to seek out movies
before i actually did the real work
i would be ecstatic i would love that
that would be that would be amazing i
mean
i think they'd enjoy it more
uh you know i mean look i i like to
watch movies than read you know so
uh you know i think i think that would
be amazing
you know hopefully it does become uh
like the new generations
you know like romeo and juliet like
razzlerman's did
you know previously uh and you know yeah
if they may go back and read the
original thing and go wait
this this but i like that movie more
i was definitely if you couldn't tell
more of a movie watcher than a reader
growing up
yeah one thing i really did want to ask
you about is
your choice to stick with uh the
shakespearean dialogue because
that's a very bold choice and it was
making me wonder
did anyone along the way try to steer
you
in another direction to have uh you know
that kind of dialogue paired with a
modern storytelling style when we have
so many other shakespeare adaptations
that do away with that part and simply
just set their story in modern day
sure sure yeah there was a little bit of
um question about it and the question
was more so like
well should we just keep it consistent
if they're gonna speak
shakespeare language should we have the
texting be the same or vice versa
but i thought one i wanted to hear
that language come out of our
character's mouths i wanted that
um and i also wanted to you know
respect the original text you know let's
speak it and i thought these actors
would be able to handle it um and and do
a great job with it
and also on top of that this movie felt
like to me like a mashup
you know what i mean like everything was
like you know with the music and the
style
and the um you know the
the the the language so i thought yeah
let's put those two
together hopefully it's not gonna be
jarring
and you know have this sort of mashup
idea from top to bottom in this film
if you could apply the same type of
filmmaking to any other uh
piece of shakespeare's work what what
would it be and why someone
recently uh said something about othello
um but i don't know that i don't know
that story that much i
i was to be honest i was never like a
big shakespeare person
uh so i couldn't i don't have that like
in my memory bank to go
you know i mean i kind of like that that
approach to adapting his
work though because if you're not a fan
and you're putting your spin on it it
probably then makes it more
accessible to somebody else who might be
feeling that way
yeah i mean i was you know i wouldn't
say i wasn't a fan
i just was never i wasn't like a big
like you know
big into but i also feel like that
probably
opened me up to a lot of the changes i
made
you know in the story and and you know
things because i wasn't like
holding on to it so closely
um and giving it you know trying to give
it like a different spin
coming up with that question with a
colleague of mine the first thing that
came to mind though was
you putting your spin on taming of the
shrew this might just be because of 10
things i hate about you but something
about that story
feels like it would well suit the
the modern version of social media use
versus the public version of that versus
what goes on in dms there's just
there's something there okay okay i'm
convinced there is
you know basil has an interface or
listing maybe that that might be the
next thing
speaking of the next thing i don't know
what you could say about whatever you're
working on next but
just so uh people get hyped to continue
to follow your work from here
what is cooking right now is it
something else in the screen life zone
or something completely different
something different i'm a
pre-production on the feature version of
my short emergency
that was uh that was at sundance a
couple years ago so i'm super excited
about that
to expand that world and live with those
characters
more is there any new tool in your tool
kit that you feel yourself applying to
that
that you know came from your experience
making romeo and juliet
as of now no i'm just happy to have
the freedom to do shot reverse shot
again and have an objective
pov because romeo and juliet was all
subjective
and that was interesting to play in that
in that box a little bit that but it
also had me
push me to figure out how to get out of
that box but i'm
i'm ready to go back out put the camera
here put the camera here here like you
know so
yeah very very very fair
big congratulations on romeo and juliet
i can't wait to see
what else you deliver from here thank
you you are
having a wonderful time at sundance ah
thank you so much